la loi dite loi anticasseurs suscite des
remous au parlement et dans l'opinion
publique
c'est bien ce que vous avez entendu un
projet de loi anti casseurs en 1970 deux
ans après mai 68 et ses pavés georges
pompidou demande à son gouvernement de
rédiger une loi afin de contenir les
débordements lors des manifestations
explication du projet par le porte
parole du gouvernement a les chefs et
organisateur de ce rassemblement qui à
partir du moment où les désordres
commence n'auront pas à donner l'ordre
de dislocation seront puni de six mois à
trois ans de prison
des organisateurs punis même s'ils n'ont
pas été violents
c'est le concept de responsabilité
collective et ce n'est pas tout déjà la
notion de casseurs pilleurs était mise
en avant pour paraphraser le mot du
premier ministre les casseurs auront
compris qu'ils risquaient d'être le
payeur il réside non lanceront à être
les casseurs c'est le bien que je le
reçois l'opposition fustige cette loi
qui selon elle est liberticide
nous au doigt notre code pénal
permettent de répondre à cette question
en vérité le gouvernement a saisi
l'occasion comme s'ils avaient voulu
profiter des circonstances
c'est ainsi que en fait il interdit
désormais le droit de manifester le
droit de se rêver en vérité le
gouvernement fait une loi de police
malgré ces oppositions la loi est votée
en juin 1970 et son application ne
tardera pas un lycéen accusé d'avoir
frappé un policier est condamné gilles
guyot cet élève du lycée chaptal
condamné à six mois de prison dont trois
avec sursis on reproche à g lui you
d'avoir participé activement à la
manifestation du secours rouge de la
semaine dernière en appel il sera relaxé
faute de preuves selon le juge
autre exemple en 1979 lors d'une
manifestation de soutien aux
sidérurgistes qui dégénère sans
vingt-et-une personnes manifestant
badauds ou passants sont arrêtés 32 sont
jugés en correctionnelle
dont un lycéen gilles des treize accusés
d'avoir lancé des projectiles sur les
forces de l'ordre
une accusation basée uniquement sur les
témoignages des policiers tout comme la
sphère guillaud je tiens à 3,6 y est à
préciser que j en aucun cas la lancer
des projectiles
le mineur a été condamné à une peine de
prison ferme
une condamnation qui fera grand bruit
les parents les enseignants et les
lycéens entendent protester contre les
arrestations de casseurs le 23 mars
dernier à paris et ils protestent
notamment contre l'aggravation de la
peine d'un lycéen condamné à 18 mois de
prison
françois mitterrand candidat à
l'élection présidentielle en 1981
inscrit dans son programme
l'abrogation de cette loi promesse tenue
sept mois après son élection
[Musique]